mais venus sur des gones à l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs et bonnes
années 2000 ce soir avec éloi rolland
jeune en maître international
bonsoir stephen aura tous vos soirées
loi et un invité
il s'agit de bertrand guyard bonsoir
bertrand ont soir stéphane soirée loi
donc battre en guyane organisateurs
d'événements chic et un tu peux nous
répète à une carrière longue et en tout
cas depuis quelques années tu
t'organises des événements où tu es
qu'organisateur organisateurs ou à
l'origine d'événements et j'y tiens
voilà voilà c'est ma passion pour les
échecs qui me poussa et aider le jeu
d'échecs en organisant des des tournois
mais aujourd'hui on n'est pas venu pour
faire les mois ci un petit peu je vais
peut-être me raconter un peu qu'est ce
que tu avais qu est ce que tu as pu
organiser ou organisées dans très
rapidement moi je suis un joueur
d'échecs je suis un joueur d'échecs et
je suis passionné j'aime bien jouer j'ai
joué beaucoup j'ai aujourd'hui comme je
travaille je joue certes en partie
rapide et on a surtout organiser un open
à bourbon-lancy dont je m'occupe d'un
centre culturel rue la jonquière dans le
17e arrondissement où on organise des
simultanée déjà avec avec machart quoi
tu lis avec yossi woerth man avec un
atelier weiser et puis je crois que
on va parler aujourd'hui déflorer le
sujet mais on a peut-être nous apparaît
un projet ensemble we appt est en
progrès d'organiser effectivement à un
grand prix d'échelle que comme celui de
bordeaux voilà qui donc avec des joueurs
connus
et
de faire un beau un beau spectacle face
à saint projet tu arrives aussi organisé
je crois que tu as raison ce qui s'est
passé au sénat sur lequel on a fait un
reportage
voilà donc moi je crois de façon de
sujets à discuter on a on a la même
philosophie je crois qu'en france
maintenant il ya vraiment des jeunes
grands maîtres il ya beaucoup de joueurs
qui jouent beaucoup mais il n'y a pas
grand chose de fait parce que ça a été
abandonnée en ont pendant des années
parce que c'est abandonner je crois par
les pouvoirs publics parce que les gens
avaient autre chose à penser aujourd'hui
grâce à une émission comme celle là
grâce au net grâce au développement des
échecs dans le monde grâce à un grand
champion comme kasparov
grâce à certains champions français
comme bacrot je crois qu'il ya moyen
maintenant d'organiser des des grands
tournois et bon toi tu as repris à
bordeaux l'idée du trophée chopard
finalement qu était quand même assez
pionnier en l'améliorant oui je crois
que maintenant il faut continuer ça et
on va continuer en france et puis
pourquoi pas après en europe
pourquoi pas on verra on va essayer en
tout cas alors il voit cette semaine
l'actualité internationale très très
forte avec un superbe super match à
milan est oui c'est vu évidemment
l'actualité de la semaine
échiquier nc ce match du champion du
monde qui remet entre guillemets son
titre en jeu le championnat alexander
quelques pannes qui a gagné le tournoi
brillamment de las vegas il y a trois ou
quatre mois de cela ici il joue un match
contre le jeune talent les étoiles
montantes hongroise qui terme les coûts
donc quitté l'école numéro 8 mondial et
ça donne un match assez saignant puisque
les deux joueurs en fait on un style qui
s'imbriquent bien style positionnelle
des deux côtés pour l'instant donné avec
quatrième partie alors bon transition
c'est l'histoire les chromes n'est pas
venu en 8e mondial mais numéro six
mondial depuis le 1er janvier nous file
quelques jours effectivement la
progression va plus vite que qu'on le
croit donc peter & co a gagné des points
c'est pas forcément une surprise
puisqu'il est vraiment un joueur
exceptionnel donc je pense qu'on peut
commenter ce nouveau classement qui est
sorti en janvier même tout à fait avec
la première place donc sans surprise je
pense que quand on est tous d'accord là
dessus
le plus grand joueur du siècle voire
même du millénaire c'est garry kasparov
effectivement garry kasparov toujours
d'un bar one avec une petite remarque
quand même je l'avais déjà fait l'année
dernière c'était la même exactement la
même
remarque d'ailleurs numéro un nombre de
parties jouées 0 solide qu'elle n'a pas
perdu deux parties effectivement il n'a
pas joué mais il faut dire qu'il a
énormément joué dans la dans une
certaine période qui était le don le
début d'année 1999 il ya beaucoup de
tournois et là il est en train de se
reposer ils ont un peu une sorte de
repos du guerrier
il se repose il n'a pas joué deux
parties et donc effectivement le fameux
défaut du classement elo la chose qui
remet en cause ce classement
quand le joueur ne joue pas il conserve
son placement ce qui amène ce genre de
résultat qu'est ce que tu en penses
bertrand oui on pas que vous voyez comme
ça et de garder ses secrets sont vous
connaissez l'histoire du classement et
n'obéissent qu'à l'origine arpad lots le
professeur l'avait créée pour le tennis
c'est un bon classement
le classement est long mais comme tous
les classements c'est un classement qui
est basée sur les probabilités
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui si dès lors
de d'expliquer comment ça se passe c'est
sûr que si on veut réellement développé
le jeu il faudra peut-être qu'il ya un
classement plus réactif oui mais bon
dans le cadre kasparov
le problème de kasparov s'est passé
parce à mon sens le pam de kasparov
c'est qu'aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il est
il est vraiment plus fort que les autres
et que bah il n'a pas toujours envie de
jouer avec les autres s'ennuie mais non
mais simple façon c'est le problème
aujourd'hui du japon a le plus grand
champion depuis non seulement un énorme
champion mais en même temps un
personnage médiatique
on a une chance extraordinaire et en
même temps
il faut reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui le
monde des échecs ne l'utilisent pas en
pros plein de raisons et
mais on va le voir justement avec ce
fameux e
on a parlé un peu du match qualif man
contre les co qualif ma des champions du
monde en titre et joue contre les
coquets un super histoire mondiale mais
qui n'est pas kasparov
ils souffrent dans le match donc
aujourd'hui il faut réunifier tout ça
nous on a envie de polémiquer parce
qu'on est on est journaliste mais je
crois qu'il faut essayer de dire du bien
du jeu d'échecs et simon polémique on va
finir par en dire du mal là on retrouve
dire du mone simplement bon soutien
petite remorque sur ce classement elo le
tennis a choisi depuis tout récemment de
remettre à chaque fois chaque année les
pendules à zéro alors peut-être c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut préférer aux
échecs alors il faut savoir que si on
veut comparer au tennis et que au tennis
c'est l'apanage la force de jeu des
champions fluctue plus du fait de
blessures de fatigue et aux échecs man
était tous kasparov et numéro 1 mondiale
depuis quinze ans maintenant 15 ans et
on va parler de karpov pour le grand
public un box bon c'est vrai qu'il a un
peu baissé on va y venir alors je te
renvoie continue de ce classement donc
numéro 2 3 4 nous ne bouge pas on
retrouve un ordre kramnik shirov et on
retrouve aussi morose et fitch qui avait
déjà créé la surprise en étant numéro 5
au dernier classement dont ces vies de
ceux qui jouent peu quand même un peu
qui joue peu cette partie cents alors
que les autres n'ont pas peur de se
remettre en cause
tant que leurs places sont un bien car
je crois que le problème est morose et
dietsch casse ne joue pas parce qu'il a
permis de jouer que je ne joue pas parce
qu'il est pas invité
depuis qu'il a son classement il attend
un peu d'être quand même invité dans les
grands tournois
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'imitations là on
va parler d'un problème encore plus
qu'avant tout et la saxe est un problème
aussi d'argent pourquoi dans les
pourquoi kasparov ne joue peu c'est
parce qu'il demande chers ils demandent
les autres les morose et beach faut
savoir que vous avez des super grand
maître qui sont entre 2006 et 2007 et
qui sont loin de ces 10 et 10 meilleurs
joueurs et qui dès qu'ils arrivent à
il commence à devenir des super joueurs
ils savent qu'ils peuvent commencer à
demander de l'argent l'argent on peut
peut-être donner les chiffres c'est à
dire 50 cent mille francs 200 mille
francs pour être invité ouais et
évidemment de cent mille francs par
joueur pour un organisateur c'est cher
c'est voilà c'est aussi pour des raisons
économiques qui joue peu et puis
gentiment l'une des raisons à prendre
continuent ils à 13h mais c'est très
intéressant de voir ce que tu dis alors
mur aussi cela la demi surprise on va
dire de ce classement on s'y attendait
il a quand même gagné le tour de contes
de vaincre amis justement demain ans de
la dame sait c'est peter l'écho qui est
vraiment qui ce qui est en train en tout
cas à mon sens vraiment j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir une trajectoire digne
d'un futur candidat au titre
je pense que la norme chroniquer chirouf
peut se poser des questions peuvent
avoir peur de la montée de l'icco non
une autre marque très rapidement déjà
séduit par kasparov les cinq autres
joueurs que tu as cités sont des joueurs
qui ont moins de 30 ans à nantes à 30
ans et les autres ont 24 pour ramener
coûte 23 l'écho 19 20 chf à 28 provinces
à 108 oui tout à fait c'est la nouvelle
et puis je crois qu'ils vont être là
pendant encore quelques années oui c'est
pas tout à fait la nouvelle vague en
fait dans la mesure où ça fait quand
même longtemps qu'ils sont qui sont
installés les le nouvel arrivant c'est
morose et beach il ya clairement fait un
bond énorme les derniers en gagnant 100
points elo wassa placement puis tire les
beaux montait en puissance lentement
mais sûrement
c'est à dire que ça fait très longtemps
qu'on en parle descoings a toujours été
modeste dix ans je ne serais peut-être
pas champions du monde mais peut-être
quand même et là il monte il monte il
gravit les échelons petit à petit et la
numéro six mondial qui gratte ça se
rapproche et il arrive vraiment il
commence à jouer vraiment bien
ouais vraiment très bien qu c'était
bacrot dit complètement mais sur la
version complète eric etienne bacrot on
va arriver aussi dans ce top 10 alors
numéro 7
il a gagné aussi des points
c'est michael adams après un très bon
championnat du monde longtemps puisqu'il
est quand même arrivé en demi finale
c'est une fourmi qui lui réussit bien
puisque la dernière fois et arrive en
finale contre un homme donc qu'il y
arrive toujours sur le demi-fond au
final dans les stands
je crois qu'ici on est on aime bien les
échecs et le tennis pour faire les
comptes par exemple les cinq ans qu des
talents d autres naissains il ramène là
il ramène ma balle ouais 1 dames c'est
ça sa force et loi et je suis intact
tout à fait d'accord faut dire adams a
des grosses qualités sportives disons
ils travaillent moins que les autres
donc j'ai en tout cas dans ce sens là on
peut dire que oui que c'est un crocodile
c'est à dire qu'en fait il
il n'a pas forcément le niveau des
autres dans la mesure où ils travaillent
moins que les autres mais il est là il
ya le calmer les nerfs qui lui
permettent de se maintenir vraiment un
niveau égal à gagner excellent tout en
travaillant clairement moins que les
autres alors on trouve à la place numéro
8 bon ça fait un moment qu'il est dans
le top 10 vassily ivanchuk qui se
maintient on entend peu moins mieux - de
parler maintenant ils vont tous que
c'est un peu là le cas à venir il va
retrouver des niveaux de succès voilà
c'est exactement le contraire dames
c'est un travail effréné un travail jour
et nuit
il ne vit que pour les échecs ce leçon
de ce film une sorte de fiche et un
petit fischer moderne qui n'arrive pas à
sortir du groupe et donc tous 30 tout
son travail finalement ne lui sert donc
entre guillemets à rien puisqu'il est
donc dans les dix meilleurs mondiaux
sans plus alors qu'avec la quantité de
travail fourni qui doit être équivalente
à celle d'un kasparov
on aurait pu espérer plus de ce joueur
qui promettait énormément il ya une
dizaine d'années alors pour conclure sur
tous ces classements on va arriver donc
9e barrier fbi ni barrière qui gagne
quelques points 10e veselin topalov
aussi qui était un top 10 c'est la
dernière fois
le palois une 12e et 11e alors par
contre là c'est on peut commenter un
petit peu c'est la surprise un petit peu
pour la première fois depuis depuis
combien de temps depuis le 30 ans qui
n'est pas dans les
trente ans pour la première fois il
n'est pas d'un d'ivrognes en duos et
anatolie anatoly karpov un territoire
pauvre qui perd qui perd pas mal de
points 15 points qui se retrouvent donc
11e mondial c'est une petite révolution
des roses 50 ans l'année prochaine
il est né en 1900 l'inter de l'a31 ouais
ouais non mais faut voir que l'effective
man tu la vie car pas au fils était déjà
pratiquement dans le numéro cinq mondial
en 70 né en 2000 face il a compté 30 ans
longue c'est quand même et violent
bon c'est vrai qu'on commence ce mais là
j'ai pas sous les yeux c'est tout ça ça
se joue à quelques points elo oui mais
sur un ouais faut qu on peut peut-être
rappeler qu'en allemagne quant à quoi ça
correspond au classement elo on peut
dire que que 400 points lourds une
différence de 4 100 points le haut entre
deux jours c'est à dire que le plus fort
va gagner à 100% ainsi probabilités et
après ça
200 points russell 75% ou etc donc quand
il ya deux points elo oui c'est ça c'est
du 50-50 mais c'est vrai que
sportivement ça certaines syfy c'est
quand même une certaine signification
c'est sûr que les cartes pas qu'il est
sur le point de descendre car peu fait
clairement se répondent descendante donc
clairement due à son âge
maintenant ce qu on peut mentionner
aussi dans ce classement c'est la 28e
place de victor victor cornol toujours
là voilà il a perdu beaucoup de points
mais je ne sais pas quel âge avait quand
même peut-être que tu peux tomber les
appels lui va avoir à soixante dix ans
il va laisser passante etc et il a vingt
ans exactement 20 ans de différence avec
impatiente l'huile est né en 1931 way
est toujours là quand même c'est quand
même quand les clés on parle pas bien
ces femmes 28 jan lamberts g sardine est
ressassé que ce qui seront diversement
trouve ailleurs l'écho 20 ans 6 mondial
et 28e mondial 78 cortège s'est vraiment
fait la beauté des schémas et ça c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est top
et j'ai dit paul claret a perdu quelques
points elle se retrouve 30e mondial à
l'effet yo-yo depuis quelques années
comme ça entre la 10e et puis la
troisième place elle a du mal a du mal à
passer la dixième en effet c'est une
classe un peu fatigué c'est top 10 ouais
mais bon
alors elle a arrêté un peu duos échec
pendant un an c'est ça je pense que la
démonétisation c'est ça le problème
alors on va donc on va finir sur ce
match de qualif man l'écho et loi
donc là on avons fini enfin pardon
finissent au classement on va continuer
sur ce match qualif man l'écho donc le
match que maintenant les coûts mène par
3 les copains de gagner la quatrième la
troisième ou la quatrième partie pardon
il ya à peu près il ya une heure lumière
de sa voix il ya eu dix ans de cela
donc on va rappeler chronologiquement ce
qui s'est passé dans ce match et la
première partie donc le champion du
monde qualifie comme un navet les blancs
il a il en a pas profité puisqu'il a
fait nul donc il n'a pas réussi à percer
la défense comme feld employés par qui
tire l'écho deuxième partie critères
d'éco avec les blancs s'est imposée
brillamment une partie qu'il a dominée
de bout en bout une partie de ses
brillantes
il a pris la paire de fouet au début il
a il a tout fait travailler très bien et
s'est donc imposé dans la deuxième avec
les blancs et troisième parties nulles
une fois plus khalifa n'a pas réussi à
passer la grogne feld de peter l'écho
donc on était amis match qualif man
menait donc il est mené par khiter
l'écho ou 2.1 donc là on a supposé que
les joueurs allaient travailler il ya un
jour de repos est donc plus tarder
coïncidé avec les blancs moi je
m'attendais personnellement à ce qu'ils
jouent solide pour maintenir son avance
ce qui aurait été une bonne une
stratégie correct avec deux fois les
blancs à venir jouer solides avec les
blancs mais non il a il a joué agressif
il a très vite attaqué en poussant
d'options sur l'école vers le roi de
kezman et s'est imposé une nouvelle fois
dans le style brillant
donc ça fait 3 à 1 pour picard l'écho
passer un examen score assez durs pour
un champion du monde en tout cas ouais
c'est vrai donc enfin il reste deux
parties et donc spécial puisque on va à
budapest est loin donc spécialement ne
reviendra une émission met donc ce sera
une spéciale
deux spéciales d'ailleurs ami sûr en
anglais et en français la semaine
prochaine avec donc des images en direct
de budapest
enfin prise à budapest en tout cas on
essaiera de ramener des interviews des
joueurs des organisateurs des
commentateurs des observateurs et des
images du match
voilà on va revenir maintenant la partie
du jour c'est le parti qui sait jouer le
tournoi de pampelune tournant très
important aussi un peu éclipsé par le
match qu'à lisbonne n'est qu'au mais
avec de très très fort joueur fort mis
entre les 20e et 30e joueurs mondiaux
qui finalement a été gagné par nigel
short en cinq candidats au titre mondial
et ancien numéro 2 mondial et c'était
une belle prestation jusqu'à la fin du
tournoi de notre numéro un national joël
lautier
oui je vois de lautier qui a dominé le
tournoi puisqu'il était en tête d'après
des six rondes ou sept rondes
il dominait le tournoi il avait cinq
points et demi sur cette seule en tête
et là le drame il a joué contre eux
nigel short avec les blancs et il s'est
imposé contre 1 hormis dame
il n'a pas réussi enfin nigel short a
fait une très belle prestation digne je
dirais de ses belles années où il était
encore numéro deux mondial vraiment on a
senti un contrôle technique qui lui a
pas échappé même avec les noirs et donc
après cette défaite je vais là fait une
nulle et se retrouve donc finalement
dans la bonne moitié du classement mais
simplement 4e ex-aequo 4e ex-aequo alors
qu'il aurait pu terminer premiers s'ils
n'avaient pas craqué à ce moment là donc
surtout avec les blancs celui qui me
perdre très rarement avec les blancs et
qui est un score positif comme kasparov
au pommier
oui foot que la profonde du jeu de tir
et des solutions et on dit article
alors donc on va revenir l'autre partie
du jour oh pas perdre de temps sinon on
va prendre du retard
c'est la partie entre joël lautier et de
la ville à un joueur donc l'espagnol je
crois ses fans argentins non sélection
espagnole de la villa
donc je vais l'outil à l'eiblen tournant
de pampelonne je vous rappelle que pour
suivre cette partie avec nous vous
pouvez la voir sur l'écran vidéo mais
aussi à votre droite en cliquant sur le
bouton java vous rentrez sur naples est
joué par don pour entrer sur un applet
java vous pouvez suivre la partie avec
nous voilà donc plusieurs façons de
regarder la partie avec nous donc on va
démarrer cette partie joël lautier donc
aller blanc je le tiens les blancs il
joue donc contre ce joueur espagnol de
la villa garcia joue des quatre
cavaliers f6 cavaliers f3 donc là comme
d'habitude les premiers qu'une ouverture
les commentaires sont un peu toujours
les mêmes on sort les pièces et on prend
le contrôle du centre assez rapidement
j'ai six un fou en fouillant piétons
ces quatre fonds g7 53e coup j'ai fait
les clous classiques peuvent laisser
trois ans catherine coût pour les blancs
hélas au quatrième coup donc d7 d5 les
noirs se battent pour le contrôle du
centre et font une stratégie je dirais
d'explosion explosion centrale circle a
clairement on va échanger des pions sans
trop les l'option des singles à
s'échanger conclusion ces quatre les
deux pions en rouge et ensuite le plan
des noirs dans cette position sera
dominée l'option des quatre en jouant
c'est cette c5 ici pour attaquer ce tion
des 4 et la obtenir une merveilleuse
diagonale pour le fou g7 qui est là ça
c'est le plan des noirs c'est à dire que
les noirs jouent en fait assez dynamique
essaie d'éliminer ces quatre pions ces
questions sur ses 2 colonnes pour que le
fou g7 soit plus fort que le chou blanc
équivalent alors cette défense comme ça
17 des 5 au quatrième coup d'un soda
cette ouverture ça s'appelle s'avère
défense grünfeld voila ca qu en réalité
ici de la manière dont ces infos ancien
ghetto on avait le choix entre la
défense est indienne où on nous fait le
coup naturel selon les explications
d'essayer de comprendre ce que vivait et
loi c'est d'échanger maintenant le pion
c4 contre le pion des cinq mois donc ces
capteurs des cinq districts où dort mal
ça n'a pas été joué voilà donc la partie
là il faudrait reprendre ici et
maintenant le coût normal et e2 e4 où
les blonds instaure un duo tsion central
des pions e4 et des quatre avec la des
embranchements qui se poursuivent et qui
se poursuivre puisque la défense d'une
fade
on ne sait pas encore très bien où ça
arrive donc en général c'est la partie
dure de deux ou trois coups oui ça peut
il ya des suites théorique qui vont
jusqu'au 25e 30e 35e coup énormément
analyser et on peut dire je crois que
tous les grands championnats du monde
savent manier la douane fed ont
généralement et c'est évidemment que
surtout kasparov fischer quel fischer
qui était un joueur de concerts
mémorables et des dix jours du 20e
siècle
ouais valoir marc continuer sur la
partie donc là les morts ont choisi de
ne
fall et blanc choisi de ne pas prendre
directement des cinq de jouer le coup
d'amendés 3 je crois c'est la variante
aux russes oui c'est une spécialité
russe dmb 3 qui était jouée par karpov
dans son match contre cannes ce qui si
je fais pas d'erreur c'est c'est
simplement l'idée de ce coût est de
défendre l'option c4 d'accord sur ces
caps qui était en prise donc très
logiquement les noirs prennent
d'apprentis cap donc là inconvénients
pour les blancs ils ont sorti leurs
dames trop vite on dit on dit évidemment
à tous les débutants de ne jamais sortir
la dame puisqu'elle se fait attaquer l
objet de repartir mais ici c'est joué
par des grands champions alors pourquoi
et simplement parce que les blancs
obtiennent une belle compensation avec
ses pions centre où les viandes et
quatre éducatrices sont ce qu'on appelle
une majorité centrale
c'est à dire que sur ses 2 colonnes du
centre qui sont devant le royal adam
ils ont deux pions alors que les noirs
dans donc un donc voilà compensation à
100 la dame vite mais un après centres
petit rock 7e coup les blancs avance le
pion aux quatre très logiquement
et là la surprise donc leur tronc tu vas
tu arrives dans la partie que c'était
pas le coup ce travail mais c'est un
coût standard
rien de plus exactement c'est ce que tu
expliquer les freinages on peut
peut-être revient à coup avant cercle
ici 1 en avril tablant les blancs d'eau
pure centraux dans tout l'est dans tous
les bouquins dans tous les bons livres
on va dire non et si on explique que les
blancs doivent avoir ça donc si les
noirs n'attaque pas il risque de se
faire étouffer tout simplement donc ici
il ya deux manière d'attaquer sa entre 7
non c'est pas mais bon évidemment c'est
une rupture ça coûte
voilà on va montrer un sac où on va on
va peut-être faire un peu de pédagogie
des flèches vertes est loin qu'on m'a
pas plu mais bon ils en sortent plus
scott bakula et coûte très cher puisque
la case de 5 et déjà deux fois protégé
donc l'autre manière de d'essayer
d'attaquer centre avec les pions s'est
joué c'est cette c5 1 c'est le coup
qu'est ce que tu préconises est d'une
manière générale au début et je crois
que donc dans cette position je suis pas
un grand spécialiste de la grande fête
mais faut maintenant on joue alors un
coup hyper moderne qui jouait souvent de
jouer cavalier à 6-1 6-3 kasparov a
beaucoup joué ça donc le charisme et 13
assists pour pour contrôler la casse ces
5 voilà alors
ce à contrôler le cavalier évidemment va
sur le bord de l'échiquier 1 mais ils
contrôlent la casse et 5 et en même
temps ça n'obstrue pas la sortie du fou
c'est 8 impasse qu'il pourrait le faire
avec le cavalier en 17 mois je crois que
c'est l'une des variantes ou casser la
variante joué par kasparov
effectivement je me rappelle donc
kasparov en nationwide problème dans
cette position bon c'est pas une
surprise puisque rapport descoings
couverture d'accord donc alors qu'à
venir si c'était pour éviter le coup
standard donc là les noirs donc on
choisit finalement de jouer aucune des
variantes ans et 6 mai de mettre le
cavalier 1,6 au septième coup et les
blancs ont répondu par un coup de dé
veloppement tranquille voilà qu'ils ont
peur ils ont pas peur soit curieux lit
dans sa maison
non ils n'ont pas peur puisque ce coup
n'a effectué effectivement aucune menace
et dont ils poursuivent logiquement le
troisième principe de l'ouverture
prendre le centre sortir les pièces et
le troisième principe m leroy à l'abri
donc ici c'est ce qui est préparé par
foods dont on prépare le petit rock qui
est ici donc les noirs continuent un peu
dans leur stratégie étrange avec qualité
donc là effectivement il se dirige
vraisemblablement vers la pousser au 7e
5 comme j'aurais loti que je l'obtiens
empêchent par son 9e ou en jouant des 5
ici on attaque lucas et ses six mois est
une marque très simple le pion des
attaques ce qu'avait dit la qui est la
reine est ce qu on appelle l avantage
des spasmes il avance dans le cas
inverse
oui alors qu'elle vient secouer quand
même une sorte de concession pour moi
mais parce que au coude avant donc on va
revenir sur la pression du huitième coup
le duo tout est parfait c'est à dire que
là on peut jouer on peut avancer de de
tous les côtés on peut avancer ce plan
là le pion à eux option d irak on a une
sous places maximum
voilà alors que l'arrangement son 9e ou
des cinq jeux lautier se ferment des
options c'est dire qu'ils attaquent le
cavaly prend un peu d'espacé
effectivement mais c'est fermé l'option
d'avancer ses pions
alors il a joué ça dans la mesure où les
normes de sept blocs et la position
centrale par 2 7 5
mais ce qui était mentionné qu'elle va
laisser aux cinq cavaliers prend
cavaliers donc après ces échanges forcé
on peut dire ça comme ça et la foudre le
5-fu prend 1,5 alors c'est quoi du fou
est pas dû se poser la question du pad
avec laval y est ça le qui a l'air plus
effectivement donc on va mentionné donc
l'as commençons ici c'est des variantes
aviation voilà ça n'a pas été joué dans
la partie c'est donc on disait déjà la
suite au 10e cours l'une à prendre avec
les avec le foulée une langue pu prendre
un cavalier oui alors ici simplement je
vais le titre est reparti avec la dame
en b3 et lecavalier n'est pas stable
c'est à dire que à venir la poussée f2f
4 à prévoir et les blancs vous prendre
en fait vous envoie une sorte de marée
de pions j'ai quasiment de revenir à sur
la place des sept
voilà un qui l'aurait pas il aurait été
remué réparé le fou sur la gazon double
qui contrôle très bien les cases du mal
à nier mais on est on est là pourtant
mais je suis là portant des t je fais le
candide way l'enquêté côte est et le
fouet et 5 sera pas stable non plus le
fourreau ça ne sera pas stable elle met
alors plus retour
on va dire aussi mérité de jouer après
peut-être on va voir ce qu'a dit quand
même oui alors je à mon avis donc là
c'est effectivement ces sujets à débat
je pense que sur l'avancée f4 ici met
donc au 10e coup tournoi il est possible
mais d'ailleurs en fait c'est peut-être
la partie en tête voire un an peut-être
tout c'est moyennement voire non mais
c'était drôle c'était une remarque
d'ordre général a eu tout à nyala c'est
une question le faux enceinte
effectivement pas stable c'était donc la
jouer le jeu choisi de ne pas jouer la
poussée de 4 du sud mais il a sûrement
ça dans la tête puisque ce fut
effectivement on a envie de le chasser
avec le pion donc il choisit plutôt de
sentir ses pièces ont joué le coup en
zfu g5 wakfu g5 qui s'opposent en fait à
la destruction du centre par 2 sets
aussi c'est une des possibilités afin
qu'ils investissent vidéo 6 ça qui est
un coup de en fait ils clouent le pion
le pion aux 7
voilà c'est à cela que les noirs avaient
envie d'avancer pour casser le sens car
si ceux qui ont joué devant le four
prendrait la dame derrière voilà
cavaliers b6 attaque la dame donc dams
et 5 contres attaques sur le bureau
cette wii l'action combinée des deux
pièces donc d'un mefou attaque le pion
aux 7 qui doit donc être défendu
hélas le coup et 7 et 6 alors
effectivement attaque le fou mais comme
tu dit bertrand volant partie aussi ce
coup effectivement empêche la taxe sur
le fuel au 7 mai ça empêche le fumoir de
revenir la maison tu sais ce qu'on dit
dans les toiles on dit c'est une horreur
c'est une eau voilà non mais et c'est fo
se tromper c'est ce qui est sûr bien sûr
il faut toujours être humble canton
évidemment l'on commente la partie
rapidement et fréthun de venger l'échec
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de possibilités
mais c'est vrai que si un débutant joue
sa lancée que c'est un grand match et
tout ça dans une partie de caen 26 un
débutant je vous sens lui dit reprends
ton coup c'est une horreur
non666 tout à fait effectivement c'est
très très moche c'est vraiment pas très
joli du tout je t'aime fawcett se
retrouvent arriérés mais le fou aux 5 et
coupé ne peut plus revenir à bloquer par
son propre pays oui ça fait but le roi
en finale évidemment l'avancée du tueur
aurait fait toujours prématuré on l'a
déjà dit une dizaine de fois de
diagonale parce que le roi maintenance
et il ya la grande diagonale blanche qui
est susceptible de faire des échecs
embêtant lé trou quoi on va dévoiler
tout est possible c'est une c'est une
heure c'est un quoi faiblissant mais il
n'y a pas d'autre pour les joueurs
devront être un peu plus générale que
pour les joueurs destin diène et
canfield ce qu'ils aiment c'est le fou
angers7
ils ont une sorte d'adoration et souvent
parce que c'est le fou qui se réveille
donc j'essaie de rencontrer la caraïbe
et conseillers du roi
c'est là où se développe au début ils
aiment ça brise et l'ism se fout
est-ce que ce fou se révèle là malgré
tout on sait que ce fou il va pas
pouvoir se réveiller sur les grands noms
mais donc c'est possible tout est
possible la preuve parce que d'ailleurs
avoir la suite d'un parti c'est pas si
simple mais en tout cas c'est tout à
fait en tout cas intéressant donc ici je
lautier poursuit par 13e couffo h6
menace la tour f 8 et sa contrôler une
case à côté du roi
c'est toujours un thème de maths se fout
contrôler une case à la casse g7
imaginez si la dame arrivée sur cette
case ce serait celle qu'elle a dans les
faits ça veut dire si une faiblesse en
tout cas effectivement les cases noires
dur autour du roi noir sont affaiblis
tous rêvent 7 et maintenant je loti
évidemment prend tous les chiites y ont
joué 14e coup f4 on a poussé mais ils
sont où il empêche définitivement se
fout de rentrer à la maison c'est dire
que même si l'ailé nord si maintenant
s'il avait pu jouer encore une fois le
plus bref il aurait pu imaginer vraiment
ramène le fou mais l'attaquant
maintenant il oblige les noirs à dire
que ce fou sort de cette diagonale et
maintenant tu te tuera plus
enfin en effet ctive mans est donc ici
alors il ya deux possibilités soit on
aura peut être il faut soit on va
prendre le cavalier c3 que je vais
pointer là mais bien entendu les changes
fou contre cavaliers c'est pas
acceptable déjà joué ici ses limites
sont plus joueurs deux indiennes ou de
bonnes fêtes mais alors fou prend
cavaliers c'est pas envisageable parce
qu'après les cases noires sont beaucoup
trop fait ou mal an c'est génial oui je
sais c'est que karpov luca soir avec
need you now des scellés j'ai dit ouais
ouais c'est ça peut être bien sûr une
fois effectivement food & his donc
attaque la dame je la tire rapatrie en
patrie la dame est maintenant aussi ce
donc finalement ils arrivent quand même
à casser le centre oui c'est à dire que
toute la ville a ici n'est pas
complètement ridicule et aux prix au
prix de l'affaiblissement de sang froid
quand même bien content du nord-ouest a
fait mais il a quand même aussi à 406 et
l inconvénient de cette avancée de pions
d4 d5 c'est que l'on se rapproche du
coin nuit on s'en rapproche même
tellement qu'il a plus qu'à jouer un
petit coup de cet os 6 pour pourrait
changer un peu le centre surprend aussi
ce fonds prend 1,6 donc là on en 16e
coup au 17e coup les blancs finissent
par achever leur développement avec 17
petit rock et là on voit que moi j'ai
toujours aimé le style de joël lautier
quelqu'un de très très pure puisque
toutes les pièces sont toujours au bon
endroit
c'est vraiment il obtient toujours des
très belles positions maintenant il ya
plus qu'à sortir sept tours 2-1 en bien
maryse latour sur l'un sur la grande
diagonale et vous verrez que toutes les
pièces sont placés sur la meilleure case
et ça c'est une serre dont dans les
parties de joël gauthier c'est que
toujours des cons et sorties de
l'ouverture on s'aperçoit que toutes ces
pièces sont parfaites comme cela se
passe au vert à oignies kasparov ça se
comprend aisément
17e ou fou c4 donc je lautier en fait je
vous dise 8 toa d un très logique ça y
est tout et tout est parfait là en fait
l'idée de ce coup fous ces quatre au 17e
coup c'est d'alléger un peu l'attention
c'est d'échanger des pièces
effectivement on dit souvent que
quand on sait plus quoi faire dans une
position il faut faire des échanges
c'est un des premiers principes que con
mais a pris aux échecs quand tu sais pas
quoi faire tes change ici c'est
exactement ce que fait de la villa ils
échangent il échange une pièce pour
alléger pour alléger tout ça 19e coup
d'un prend que deux dames évite la
position du roi noir est quand même
assez solide ici on se demande comment
jouer elle va réussir à passer
comment est-ce qu'il va fortifier sa
position et il trouve une solution assez
j'ai trouvé assez élégante qui est donc
au 20e coup tour des 3 la fameuse tour
sur la 3eme traverse donc c'est tout
voilà cet homme à pouvoir passer à
droite feu faire une action contre le
rock le rock et demi oui oui tout à fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle un tour nouveau
lobby qui vient de dieu joueurs italiens
alors peut-être germandrée où vous
pouvez aller à tour et loi c 17 euros là
il fallait ranger 3 voilà peu là ici et
voilà avoir une action contre le roi
voire même sur la colonne h donc passer
devant les pions comme ça quand les
pions sont encore présentes
le roi est comme ça toujours protégé le
roi blanc et la tour à une action forte
contre le roi de verviers s'est passé
les tours sur la trace de poser ses
questions et sait jamais quand
j'essayais jouer de tous rêvent d un
doublé sur la colonne d'un sait pas trop
si c'est une autre idée mais je pense
qu'on a plus récemment le renoir et on a
fait vie on voulait vraiment se
focaliser sur sur le roi autres autre
problème c'est qu'on peut aussi doubler
les tours en c1 a joué tout est fondé un
ici donc là je vais vous pointez une
batterie une batterie tout ça fera une
batterie tour en rouge ici deux tours
sur la colonne des mais c'est pas très
efficace dans la mesure où se fout des
six fait un peu le bouchon et on a du
mal à le déstabiliser
donc je pense vraiment que l'action se
passe les blancs ramènent leurs pièces
vers leur fou vers leur foi justice
c'est là qu'ils sont plus concentrées et
donc ils ramènent ils ramènent tous à la
tâche est quoi ca un jeu
un poisson d'engrenages assez clair sur
les tours c'est toujours pareil pour les
détours se lisent comme ça oui tu peux
aller dans tous les sens là c'est très
c'est toujours très souple bon c'est du
joël déjouer la tour des beats 21e
coutour g3 on y va on a fait toutes les
pièces quasiment son flow cavaillé
peut-être qu'ils tiennent encore un peu
le centre mais toutes les pièces
blanches sont vers le roi adverse le
cavaly est très important et il y tient
qui ont 4 maintenant plus long à venir
je prends son plan très simple l'avancé
du bélier h le pillage 2 qui peut
arriver jusqu'en h sainte et s'est
rapidement privés sur le pion g6 sa
prise du pian et après la tour qui
ferait un échec comme un meurtrier
donc ici une fois de plus de la vida
essaie de tenir bon échange encore une
pièce est donc là fortifie la protection
de son roi puisque ce x justice le fou
qui est ici était quand même un poison
pour le pour le tir autre noir
finalement il a dû lui remettre en fuite
donc on peut voir le lin et recours du
fou et stendhal avait forgé cette voie
là on peut montrer les cartes pas très
loin il a attiré les motifs il est
attiré 1
alors ce fonds qui au départ de futsal
offert le faux départ et ensuite
préparer tarifs 8 ensuite vient sur
cette case files 7 puis sur la case aux
5 millions dé 6,1 et finalement il
revient ce qui fait donc en fait un
parcours
c'est une perte de temps c'est un
parcours qui arrive voire même
rectangulaire me voir même plus précis a
fait son camp faut donc je vais les
changes c'est fou d'après et maintenant
donc ça a été libérée c'est possible il
joue le coup 23e f5 donc elle s'allier
créer un bélier ils menacent de prendre
un pion g6 le tallec six attaques de là
tout est attaqué par l'action à la fnac
et par la tour j'ai trop mal en tout cas
le caylar bon droit que la position du
roi noir est affaiblie c'est en fait là
c'est le point clé de la position mais
je pense qu'ici les noirs sont assez
proches d'égaliser mais ce qu'ils n'ont
rien perdu
ils ont échangé 2 2 les deux paires de
fou donc il ya plus de beaucoup de
pièces sur l'échiquier
ils ont pris la colonne ouverte donc ils
sont assez proches de les qualités
maintenant il faut qu'ils se
débarrassent vraiment du problème du roi
puis-je me permettre de faire une
réflexion
il suffirait que vers cette position et
cavaliers b6 soit sur la case 5 et
peut-être même que les noirs seraient un
tantinet mieux oui tout à fait s'il
s'agissait bien que celle ci le capital
soit menée en un sens oui comme la toile
n'aurait pas joué ce coup là rien mr mat
et à peine investi avant que ça s'est
joué à pas grand chose à part alors oui
la justification de ce que vient de dire
bertrand sexy si on arrive à mettre le
kode5
il sera vraiment responsable sur cette
case il sera indélogeable il rappelé et
de pions qui pourront l'attaqué et il
défendra complètement grand noir efforts
l'atteindre le faire certes le manoir se
retrouvera en sécurité hélas les noirs
aurait plus qu'à faire valoir leurs plus
puisqu'ils ont quand même en plus dans
cette position c'est les trois pions ici
contre deux seulement pour les blancs
voilà certes si on arrive avec lequel
0,5
donc là c'est vraiment un psy
traite ainsi certains si oui celle ci
doit peut-être donc
en fait c'est pas possible mais si on y
arrive et il y aurait la majorité à
faire valoir
donc il fait tour g7 on défend l'option
rapidement je lautier jour où agen on
compte qu'on appelle de prophylaxie donc
ça empêche avec la guerre qu elle a par
exemple joué loti voulait peut-être joué
le pion au no 5 et ils pouvaient pas à
cause de l'échec de la dame et ensuite
la dame aurait pris le pion aux 5
oui donc maintenant ils menacent
peut-être de pousser ses pions 5
ça peut être dangereux j'éprouve c'est
bien pourquoi alors là c'est là je vous
pose la question si si et parce que
visiblement nous on connaît la suite de
la partie on sait que ça c'est pas bien
pas bien passé
cavalier 17 oui alors là alors on peut
vraiment envisagé alors effectivement
les noirs puis joué le coup car et 17
qui contrôle la case 5 qui empêche
l'idée possible de malsain et manger des
mets peut-être là mais simplement de
jouer c'est de jouer dame échec et de
prendre le pion si cette voie là je
pense que le problème qu'elle et 17 dans
l'absolu c'est très bien mais donc c'est
faire un don il faut des sacrifices de
pions voilà il n'y a pas d'homme ces
quatre chèques le roi doit n'en profite
seulement 25e coup 1-1 25e coup si
l'événement a joué car les décès au 24e
et 24e coup c'est nord avec joe cole 17
$ cher voilà ça coûterait chiant et
peut-être même en deuxième
puisqu'on voit pas comment non mais ici
effectivement on peut s'arrêter en
position là effectivement donc là c'est
une variante qui a duré quatre coups les
blancs ont pris un pion les noirs se
sont replacés en 5
à mon avis la position n'est pas claire
n'est pas complètement clair ici les
noirs obtenons des compensations son
cadavre a pas beaucoup de casse donc la
dame a une case ça lui suffit à la case
à st il faut y aller mais savoir
effectivement le courage ici de se dire
c'est le moment de faire quelque chose
c'est son problème
voilà c'est exactement ça c'est le
problème quand on est en train de se
défendre c'est qu'on sait pas quand et
là qu'il faut envoyer la 9ème journée un
atout à jouer on a plus que ça dans les
mains mais
il faut vraiment maximiser son atout
vrai ici je pense que de l'avis d'anne
n'a pas jugé le moment aux produits il a
préféré continuer sa défense je dirais
barres d'acier en continuant à échanger
provoquer des changements que j'éprouve
cinq échanges des tours donc 25 25 15
coups la partie tout reprend g7 avec
l'échec d'un projet cette tour problème
donc ils échangent est depuis le début
un de la location tous les échangeurs
faut noter que la donc joël prendre de
la tour et pas du pion un oui oui c'est
logique puisque c'est touré sur une
colonne verte qui attaque directement le
pion f6 ici donc ce que je voulais juste
remarqué c'est que de la ville avait
provoqué quand même pas mal des changes
depuis qu'on était la position où ils
avaient l'air très mal il est vrai aussi
échangé deux paires de fou mais une
paire de tours et des pions ce qui est
un pas si mal il a échangé que quatre
pions de tours quatre fous il a réussi à
provoquer beaucoup des changes est
maintenant son roi se retrouvent plus ou
moins sécurité certes si l'arrivée
change les dames les noirs breuil
absolument plus aucun problème le
problème qu'on peut avoir ici c'est
éventuellement des replacements tour ou
ce genre de choses
il joue ses six maintenant donc
coûterait logique ça jusqu'à nice
ce coup contrôle jean muselet lequel les
c3 qui ne peut plus j j yi he mis en
bessin qui nie en d5 h3 la position
s'est un peu stabilisé les noirs ont une
faiblesse chronique en réussissant qu'un
coup tranquille de joie il se fait une
petite fenêtre comme on dit pour les
alors il faut le dire c'est pas le match
de couloir voilà non tout simplement
pour maintenant
il n'empêche enfin le mc du couloir
expliqué le maître du couloir dans cette
position là oui elle 6e coup une
possibilité si que si les noirs arrivé à
mettre à jour en d1 en d1 si cette tour
n'était pas en prise on voit que le roi
serait enfermée par ses propres pions
nasrallah chien ne pourrait pas monter
plus haut donc ça peut être un jour
toujours plus tard donc souvent quand on
n'a pas de coût forcément évident à
jouer tout de suite un bon coup ceux de
se prémunir pour plus tard mais c'est le
bon moment c'est le monde est-ce que
c'est souvent quand on débute on se dit
à quel moment de faire la fameuse
oreilles d'âne il faut le faire quand
y'a rien à faire pour voilà non mais
c'est ça donc ici replacements du
cavalier valider cette dame f2 petit
chatouille âge de pions c'est à dire que
la la dame attaque la dame s'est mise en
batterie avec la tour pour le pur et
6ème et subrepticement la visent un peu
le pion à 7,2 de loin en rien le petit
pion qui a l'air de rien au fond mais
bon bien entendu ça ne prend pas ça ne
prend pas de la villa par surprise et je
donc qui logiquement gratuité ou à 6 le
grand maître a vu une à vue la grande
diagonale de remettre a vu la menace est
là je le faisais ça y est a quand même
montre son plan maintenant c'est là
qu'on voit qu'il est important de créer
cette cette case puisque maintenant la
caisse des uns n'est plus du tout
contrôle et donc l'échec de la tour
devient probable donc on comprendre
l'utilité du coup h2 h3 way et joël
lautier par son dernier coup qui avait
lieu de vous replacer son cavalier très
clairement sur la case h cinq attaquants
la dame et le père et fils et surtout
l'intégralité du petit rock noir c'est à
dire que ceux qui avaient lu une fois
arrivé aux 5 sera sur zone
bon à savoir mais un f5 sur la tour
bouge avec le fameux câble link kasparov
ou le cheikh des eau a ensuite calé j'ai
trois tours vite une sorte de contre
attaque on se met un peu surtout au 4
mai la carélie kasparov trop fort
qu'avec h5 attaque la dame et le pion
même si les options abscisses et ici je
pense que là on a
dû avoir une absence de monsieur de la
villa puisque la partie n'a du recul de
coûts donc c'est assez surprenant qui
avait 10 h 5 mai ou encore une fois de
plus on voit encore joël qu'a réussi à
mettre toutes ses pièces au bon endroit
mais sûrement c'est quand même une belle
leçon il ya une faiblesse enlève 600 m
en alsace tout le monde est dessus donc
c'est là près d'am cette 32e ou les
blancs prennent l'option calais point m6
attaque natour lecavalier est en fait
les noirs ne peuvent pas reprendre le
cavalier alors ils peuvent le reprend
enfin ils peuvent lui reprendre ma
prison que le point noir est trop faible
en fait c'est uniquement un oasis c'est
vrai mais ce petit combinaison voilà
c'est le clsc les combinaisons voilà
tout point m6 là je en principe ils
avaient prévu de prendre le tueur 4
voilà c'est une sorte de coup pour coup
génial tu me prends mon pied je prends
le tien mais il ya un inconvénient
technique majeur échec au roi mais là
pour tous réfutent échec deux
possibilités ouais donc la première
qu'on va éliminer rapidement c'est de
jouer tout reprend tour qui réfutait par
dame prend tout d'un pro tour échecs et
maintenant voilà ce que le roi n'a plus
de même plus de repli et la deuxième est
très facile aussi l'autre possibilité
est roi g7 et la dame f2f six échecs et
mat
une sorte de maths je ne sais pas comme
on l'appelle ce matelas d'ailleurs je
suis pas spécialiste je sais pas des
tableaux de mad mais en fait vous êtes
un beau match c'est certain nombre donc
l'événement en fait ne peuvent pas du
coup on reprend deux points 4 ils ont
droit très faibles donc les noirs les
blancs menaces notamment peut-être le
coutour et vii est en tout cas
consolider leurs pions de plus est
je valorise à lancer facilement souvent
quand on commande des partis comme ça
pas grand public c'est quand même pas
rien si on jouera g7
ouais et loi j'essaie alors un colis des
eaux oui effectivement rejet set parce
qu'il ya quand même qu'un seul pion
conception moi je pense que ça que ça
suffira alors ici effectivement à mon
avis donc simplement un coup de
consolidation quand dans le style de
tours f4 conservant le point de plus je
pense pas été devant de forcer à moins
que là on a eu ce simple coup de
consolidation avec des idées comme par
exemple d'alger 3 échecs ici ou alors où
d'autres ou autour j'ai quatre échecs
également ça va faire trop les noirs ne
peuvent ils ont la dame qui est scotché
à la case hausse est à la défense de
cette 7e traverse puisqu'il ya toujours
du tours fc est dans l'air que je les
pentes et envers tout rêve cet échec
qu'il faut absolument contrôler ouais
mais c'est une messe est un gars
technique s'est inventé internet même
salaire que ce n'est pas si simple
il n'y a pas de là ça se finit en art
déco mais est pourquoi le plus en plus
est si fort dans cette position c'est
parce qu'en fait ça tous les échanges
rapproche les besoins de la victoire
donc les pièces blanches bien placé
pourront pas être délogés par exemple
touré fuite ici dans la pression que
vous avez sous les yeux permettra un
échange général avec transposition dans
cette finale option qui serait gagnante
pour les blancs alors donc une très
jolie et victoire d'alain vautier donc
on l'a dit jouets l'après krach en fin
de tournoi
moi je leur fournis la médaille quelque
sorte c'est quand même pas c'est pas le
premier venu ces caresses et même quand
même pas le premier il a créé une très
très belle partie des jouets sa
spécialité et n'oublions pas qu'il
attende réussi à tenir pas mal de
candidats contre garry kasparov
donc c'est pas une surprise qui n'en
gagnent de temps en temps également
orange judit polgar fait un tour un peu
un demi tête avec quatre points incluant
neuf secteurs restent performants c'est
plein de super résultat par contre
l'adhésion la surprise on va s'arrêter
là pour ce tournoi la surprise c'est
le jeune vallejo pons
paco ou francis compte comme on veut
puisque français pas causé diminutif de
francisco une plaie plutôt pas qu'aux
jeunes espagnols qui doit avoir un peu
moins de 20 ans mais moi j'avais moins
de 20 ans j'ai enfin je le connais un
petit peu c'est une star mais de temps
en espagne parce que au tournoi de
minorque aux championnats du monde des
jeunes ya quatre ans lorsque j'étais
avec etienne bacrot il était déjà très
connu oui annaba puisque c'est un il a
dit il est un champion du monde il a été
champion de monde de fès a presque en
tout cas d'un lacet catégorie
visiblement une continuer à progresser
voilà un ça prouve qu'en tout cas non
seulement il ya des jeunes de 18 20 22
25 ans mais il ya aussi derrière des
jeunes de maintenant c'est terrible le
jeu d'échec c'est un véritable sport en
son nom c'est bien venez chez moi je les
ai vus aussi également championnat du
monde des moins de 10 ans à fond du lac
aux états unis hier j'avais 14 ans donc
il a 80 quoi ressembleront et il avait
il était en concurrence avec notre
espoir notre ex espoir national
adrien le roi n'en est qu'à l'époque
donc et il semble qu'il ait fait il
avait terminé sur le podium en tout cas
oui je crois qu'ils sont vice champions
champions n'ont pas peut-être pas
champion mais vice champion
à l'époque oui donc fait des pros n'est
pas n'est pas non plus le dernier des
derniers venus
c'est un petit peu donc le maquereau
c'est un petit peu c'est pas croiser
pagnol c'est une belle croisière
espagnol et il fait un très bon résultat
dans ce tournoi de très haut niveau que
malheureusement etienne pour l'instant
n'a pas eu l'occasion de jouer ce type
de tournoi non il faudrait qu'ils
puissent être invité dans un tournoi
comme ça de ce niveau là on va s'en
occuper on va s'en occuper on sait en
revanche il s'en occuper en tout cas on
en parlera aux organisateurs voilà donc
très jolie tourne en tant que l'une
voilà donc on va passer maintenant à
ben je crois un autre rendez vous
habituer notre rendez vous habituels la
une d un des éléments très appréciée de
diagonale il s'agit de la rubrique donc
la rubrique les rubriques habituelles de
la rubrique de josé bon alors oui de
josé à toi voilà qui va recevoir sont
limitées
alors bonsoir chers internautes et bonne
année vous donc aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance de recevoir un jeune est sérieux
candidat au titre de mai comme à ce
maître international
on l'appelle goldau il s'appelle lionel
gold beach où pend soir josé soir lionel
donc comme d'habitude je te tutoie parce
que je connais depuis très longtemps
donc voilà alors hommes jeudi qu'il
était un jeune et salue candidats au
titre de maître international pas
pourquoi être parce que tu es pas très
loin des 2400 points elo ce qui est la
première une des premières conditions
pour être m alors combien à quel est ton
niveau au fait quel est ton placement
aurait elle alors mon classement actuel
et de 2360 points elo est effectivement
seulement 40 points ne s'est pas de ce
fameux titre international puisqu'il
faut avoir deux mille quatre cents lots
pour obtenir le titre à condition
d'avoir réalisé bien sûr les trois
hommes de m et actuellement ma situation
c'est que j'ai de normes de maître
international et il me reste finalement
la plus difficile à obtenir la dernière
mais alors le problème c'est que tu ne
joues pas puisque j'ai vu condamner que
les sentiers plaisir en partie
internationale comment comptes-tu
obtenir cette troisième nom du joueur
alors c'est effectivement une difficulté
supplémentaire dans le prochain tour moi
que je vais je vais faire j'espère
pouvoir réaliser cette norme bien sûr ne
serait ce que pour finir ce que j'ai
commencé à accomplir
donc le fait d'avoir commencé les échecs
un peu plus tard que mes précédents
invités puisque tu avais appris quel âge
quand tu as commencé alors que j'ai
commencé effectivement très tard j'ai
commencé à 14 ans et très rapidement
tout simplement parce que j'étais motivé
et que les échecs qui était pour moi
plus qu'une passion je suis arrivé un
niveau de 2000 points elo en deux ans ce
qui est une marge de progression très
très correct et puis et puis voilà tout
simplement j'ai commencé de rater un
pique-niqué mais est ce que tu as comme
excuse à empêcher de rêver au titre
suprême
ou pas vous savez tu sais josé a 14 ans
quand on commence à gagner ses premières
parties dans un domaine qu'on connaît
pas très bien comme les échecs on est un
petit peu insouciant on nourrit toujours
cet âge là beaucoup d'espoir et c'est
vrai javou comm peut-être beaucoup de
jeunes en tout cas j'espère j'ai pensé à
très longtemps je te rassure à être un
jour champion du monde
mais j'ai commencé à 14 ans peut-être
qu'à 15h30 je te rassure tout le monde
m'a dit oui m'a répondu oui à la
question sauf chabanon qui me
demandaient à quoi peut-être poser
chaque heure alors certains d'ailleurs
pense qu'il faut commencer jeune puisque
toi même tu as dit avait commencé tard
et 14 ans et quand même un âge assez
jeune c'est pas très tard williams en a
d'autres qui ont commencé beaucoup plus
tard ou mais est ce que tu penses que
c'est important
comment ces jeunes allemands alors
effectivement c'est un point important
en tout cas pour être champion du monde
ou pour être parmi les meilleurs joueurs
au monde a tout simplement parce qu'il
faut que les échecs devienne un réflexe
au niveau de la tactique au niveau des
habitudes que le joueur doit prendre
donc plus comment ce jeune comme dans
n'importe quel domaine plus ses
automatismes et ses réflexes vont se
développer naturellement
maintenant je tiens à rassurer quand
même pas mal de monde que vous
commenciez à 14 ans comme moi ou même à
un âge beaucoup plus élevé puisqu'il ya
des quatre joueurs qui ont commencé à 20
ans ou un peu un vote unique a commencé
très tard est devenu champion du monde
devenu champion du monde et même des
joueurs français je pensais à rené par
exemple qui grands mettent actuellement
que commencer dans l'es15
voilà et comment tu fais d'ailleurs pour
progresser dans tu diktat progresser
très vite étaient très motivés est-ce
que c'était la seule force d'être
motivés ou tu as travaillé avec un
professeur des cours des livres j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance lorsque j'ai commencé
très rapidement j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des entraîneurs effectivement
qui ment comme qui m'ont conseillé
donc j'ai été très bien orientées très
rapidement et
et puis bon je jouais beaucoup il faut
beaucoup joué je pense pour progresser
très pratique
et puis des cours et toi même tout seul
est ce que tu tues et arriver finalement
à lire à des livres je sais pas sur tel
ou tel thème mais ce qui les livre qui
t'ont marqué par exemple absolument j'ai
dévoré beaucoup de littérature et
chilienne dans cette période de ma vie
et les livres le livre qui m'a marqué
ses confidences sur l'échiquier de kotov
qui était pour moi une révélation pour
te dire j'ai commencé à le lire je pense
ma soir vers huit heures et se
ressemblent arrêté le lendemain vers 4
heures d'après midi j étais encore et
mais bon mais finalement c'est quand
même pas un roman il faut impliquer et
ses fausses un livre qu'il faut lire
côté du leur lire après par la suite je
pense pour appliquer des exercices
absolument sauver tout à fait sûr tous
d'accord et et bon ben je sais que tu as
côtoyé et tu connais même
personnellement très bien dense
mannschaft chef quand même suivi
l'ascension de bacrot et finalement
content il a pris c'est à dire là il te
manque un chouïa pour devenir maître ce
que je ne commente une tube en devenir
alors c'est un programme assez chargé
mais j'ai effectivement eu la chance de
pouvoir côtoyer des joueurs comme
dorfman comme etienne bacrot que j'ai vu
un petit peu évolué aussi au fur et à
mesure des ans
et ces joueurs là je pense notamment à
dorfman m'a transmis
énormément au niveau de la consacre
conception de voir les échecs je pense
que ce qui est important pour quelqu'un
qui veut progresser
bon bien bien entendu c'est le travail
personnel mais c'est aussi la méthode
c'est bien de travailler les échecs
autant faut-il savoir comment travailler
les échecs et c'est ce que m'ont appris
justement en tout cas c'est ce que je
pense avoir pu cerner chez des joueurs
aussi forts que dans schumann et comme
quatre chefs c'est cette méthode
justement soviétique puisque ont
bénéficié de toute une culture qui font
tout simplement les joueurs russes sont
les meilleurs au monde
kiki donc voilà leur conception des
échecs simplement d'accord c'est bien un
jour tu reviendras pour nous expliquer
que les 700 exception parce que
malheureusement le temps nous manque
aujourd'hui
en fait on te voit souvent jouais pas
beaucoup à paris mais plus à l'étranger
en province alors maintenant avec le net
je peux connaître tous tes résultats
pourquoi m'as-tu pouvoir je saigne
beaucoup voyagé d'accord donc c'est pas
pour cacher des mauvais résultats de
tout ça j'avais mauvais résultats contre
les influences et ipad héros et tu
maintenant je sais le sig bon tu n'es
plus professionnelle des chèques puisque
maman tu as décidé de te jouer aux
échecs professionnellement peuple attend
maintenant que tu es aussi dans une
fameuse librairie et pour finir aurait
tué un bouquin de conseiller un bouquin
à la mode qui se marchaient bien et qui
peut nous aider parce que confiant sur
l'échiquier c'est un vieux livre alors
on a reçu effectivement un livre récent
que je conseille de vue vivement à tout
le monde c'est winning pomme structure
de bab urines qui est pour moi un livre
que j'attendais depuis 5 ans minimum en
fait dans ce livre là bas burinent
analyse particulièrement toutes les
positions avec un pion isolé et la
structure spécifique du jeu qui
reviennent souvent et les analyses n'ont
absoluement puis nous explique dans
quels cas le clan violet est un point
fort dans quelqu'un c'est une faiblesse
c'est certain
une petite merveille d'accord moi je te
remercie c'était court mais je suis
contente d'avoir évité et puis à la
prochaine marche un maréchal ferrant
j'espère que ça vous a plu encore une
fois et puis au revoir
bye bye tao
et
voilà donc fin de cette rubrique dose
évidemment qu'on retrouvera la semaine
prochaine donc la semaine prochaine un
programme tout à fait accès donc 100%
qualifiant de neko eloi tu vas me nous
raconter ce qu'il va se passer
et bien là il il reste deux parties à
jouer donc ça va être très tendu
qualifiant de mener 3 1
il va je pense qu'il va jouer son
va-tout il va tout faire pour essayer de
revenir au score pour égaliser à 3-3
donc la prochaine partie avec les blancs
espérons pour le sport qui va la gagner
et qui aura une dernière partie cruciale
dimanche donc là qu'on pourra confirmera
on fera un reportage audio beats et de
demain non bien entendu domaine à partie
avec les blancs localisme on aura on
fera un reportage sur ces deux parties
on verra les images de la salle les
images du lieu
on découvrira également l'analyse d'une
des parties par par un de nos joueurs
les interviews des joueurs intérieurs
des organisateurs donc reportage complet
et spéciale sur ce match historique je
dirais un championnat qui remet son
titre en jeu trois mois après l'avoir
guidé ses pas officiel la remise en jeu
de sa remise en jeu officieuse de son
titre
c'est historique voilà ça historique et
donc on espère de faire un bon reportage
là bas donc deux émissions spéciales
puisque diagonale english il y aura donc
une version est la version anglaise de
diagonale une émission spéciale sur
budapest et suivi donc parler votre
habituel rendez vous pour la version
française donc la semaine prochaine le
vendredi avec montage tout à fait
particulier bertrand ton actualité c'est
une bonne préparation pour ce fameux
tournoi de paris que tu peux organiser
de toute façon on souhaite nous
souhaitons organiser mais souvent un
délit c'est quand même fou qu'en france
on le dit il n'y a pas de grands
tournois d'échecs à part le tournoi de
bordeaux
justement je crois que c'est mon
ambition de créer un circuit déjà
français et ça serait vraiment
formidable
mandic ans avec avec
avec ton ami qui va ça va être bon
on espère que je voulais rajouter un
petit mot c'est vrai que font polémique
on est journaliste et de la semaine
prochaine il ya aussi peut-être des
commentaires politiques au sens noble du
terme sur le match l'écho kalichman oui
parce que c'est aussi le khalife man
c'est le représentant de la fidh et
malgré lui même a gagné je pourrais tu
as déjà dit ah c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
immer noch l'occasion effectivement de
commenté en latin le résultat parce que
non mais c'est le sport qui n'a pas
évolué on est passionné d'échecs donc on
va voir des belles parties exactement
tout à fait on espère encore ce match va
nous réserver de bonnes surprises
il est déjà passionnant les parties sont
tout à fait passionnante à suivre
je crois aussi que tu tu prépares
d'autres choses puisque tu lui je ne
sais pas ces fonds par des signes c'est
vrai qu'on est en l'an 2000 bravo on
sait tous maintenant et on a l'ambition
de faire une super simultanée entre un
grand champion
à paris deux mille joueurs contre un
super grand champion mais là aussi est
ça tout ça ça coûte cher de ça coûte
cher mais c'est le problème avec la
passion soulève les montagnes donc voilà
deux mille 2000 joueurs simultanés
organisé par bertrand guyard bientôt
donc à l'hôtel de ville
retransmis par la bbc indirects et bien
évidemment donc en tout cas on espère
tous les meilleurs succès dont des
nantais dans ces entreprises on espère
que tu vas encore nous réserver de
belles demeures organisations comme ça
nous donne rendez-vous donc pour la
semaine prochaine et donc se mettre
kalichman échos et la présence de
beaucoup de surprises puisque on ira
aussi à des cases et il est très
probable aussi comment suivre y est on
est un goût direct à cannes pour le
match peut-être un treuil etienne va
creuser un peu l'écart pense mais c'est
pas encore sûre en tout cas il y aura
peut-être aussi linares vers de belles
images du grand tournoi de linares donc
beaucoup d'actualité dans les deux mois
qui viennent surtout le tournoi de beach
country surtout et 15 aides en 12
semaines avec gaspard avec garry
kasparov là on espère quand même voilà
on espère du bas et du haut niveau et
met enfin jouer voilà donc spécial
spécial ados semaine spéciale souhaite
donc deux semaines ou trois semaines ou
dans trois semaines et 360 du mois de
janvier soit leur spécialité 28 janvier
dragonage spécial wecan faisait avec
caspar enfin non etc et la purée au
point et la pirogue
oui
on